president biden is battling two major
issues one is immigration
the other georgia's sweeping new and
contentious election law
mr biden condemned the overhaul that
limits voting access in the state
after republican governor brian kemp
signed the measure
separately president biden is facing
growing criticism
about the government's handling of the
surge of central americans on the
southern border who are seeking asylum
and overwhelming facilities there
christina rafini is at the white house
christina good morning
good morning elaine as you mentioned the
bidet administration is scrambling to
try to process what's now 18 thousand
migrant children
in u.s custody at the same time voting
rights advocates are trying to process
what to do about this new law in georgia
the restrictions in which president
biden has called an atrocity
[Applause]
protest raged outside the state capitol
in atlanta friday
we're taking our fight to the streets
we're taking in the courtroom
after republican governor brian kemp
signed the controversial bill in a
private ceremony
one more time this state representative
was arrested after knocking on the
governor's closed door
are you serious no for over 10 years i
have led the fight to strengthen
protections at the ballot box
kemp says the law is aimed at preventing
voter fraud
but opponents say it's less about voter
protection than voter suppression
the new law does expand early voting
days statewide
but also enacts stricter id requirements
on absentee ballots
reduces early voting for runoff
elections and
makes it a crime to deliver food and
drink to people waiting in line
you can't provide water for people
about to vote give me a break landing in
wilmington last night
president biden was asked if there's
anything the white house can do
we don't know quite exactly what we can
do at this point the justice department
is taking a look as well
voting rights is just another item on
the president's growing to do list
2 thousand miles away separate groups of
republican and democrat lawmakers toured
the southern border
because the american people have a right
to know what is happening here where a
surge in unauthorized
crossings especially by unaccompanied
minors
has overcrowded detention facilities and
pushed resources to the brink
we're here today to go back to
washington and offer recommendations
for how this process can be improved
and from a border crisis to a climate
crisis the white house also announced
yesterday it will be hosting a virtual
climate summit
inviting 40 countries including china
and russia now the russian news agency
tas said president
putin has no plans to attend the chinese
have yet to rsvp
jeff christina thank you very much